here's the second problem from ck-12 dot
orgs ap statistics flex book it's an
open source a textbook essentially on
I'm using it essentially to get some
practice on some statistics problem so
here number two the grades on a
statistics midterm for a high school are
normally distributed with a mean of 81
and a standard deviation of 6.3 all
right calculate the Z scores for each of
the following exam grades draw and label
draw and label a sketch for each example
we could probably do it all on the same
example but you know the first thing
we'd have to do is just remember what is
a z-score what is a z-score z-score is
literally just measuring how many
standard deviations away how many
standard deviations away from the mean
from the mean from the mean just like
that so we learned just have to
calculate how many standard deviations
each of these guys are from the mean and
that's their z-scores
so let me do number or part a so we have
65 so first we can just figure out how
far is 65 from the mean let me just draw
one chart here that we could use the
entire time so if this is our
distribution see we have a mean of 81 so
we have a mean of 81 that's our mean and
then a standard deviation of six point
three so our distribution say saying
they're telling us that it's normally
distributed so I can draw a nice bell
curve here they're saying that it's
normally distributed so that's as good
of a bell curve as I am capable of
drawing this is the mean right there at
81 and the standard deviation is six
point three so one standard deviation
above and below is going to be six point
three away from that mean so if we go
six point three in the positive
direction that value right there is
going to be eighty seven point three if
we go six point three in the negative
direction where does that get us that is
close what seventy four point seven
seventy four point seven right if we had
six it will get
to 80 point seven and then point three
will get us to 81 so that's one standard
deviation below and above the mean and
then you would add another six point
three two goes to standard deviations so
on and so forth so that's the at least a
drawing of the distribution itself so
let's figure out the Z scores for each
of these for each of these scores so 65
or each of these grades 65 is how far 65
is you know it's maybe going to be here
someplace so we first want to say well
how far is it just from our mean from
our mean so the distance is we just want
a positive number here well actually you
want a negative number because you want
your z-score to be positive or negative
negative would mean to the left of the
mean and positive would mean to the
right of the mean so we say 65 minus 81
so that's literally how far away we are
but we want that in terms of standard
deviations so we divide that by the
length or the magnitude of our standard
deviation so 65 minus 81
let's see 81-65 is what it is 5 plus 11
it's 16 so this is going to be minus 16
over 6.3 and take our calculator out and
let's see if we have minus 16 divided by
6.3 you get minus 2 point
well looks like 5/4 so approximately
equal to minus 2.5 4 that's the z-score
for a grade of 65 pretty straightforward
let's do a couple more let's do all of
them 83 so how far it is away from the
mean what's 83 minus 81 it's 2 grades
above the mean but we want in terms of
standard deviations how many standard
deviations so this was part a a was
right here this was a we were 2.5
standard deviations below the mean so
this was Part A one two and then point
five so this was a right there 65 and
then Part B 83 83 is going to be right
here a little bit higher where right
here
and the z-score here 83 minus 81
/ 6.3 will get us
let's see clear the calculator so we
have well 83 minus 81 is 2 / 6.3 0.32
roughly so here we get 0.32 so 83 is
0.32 standard deviations above above the
mean and if so it'd be roughly one-third
of the standard deviation along the way
right because this was one whole
standard deviation so we're 0.3 of a
standard deviation above the mean choice
number see we're not choice Part C I
guess I should call it 93 well we do the
same exercise 93 is is how much above
the mean well it's it's 93 minus 81 is
12 but we want it in terms of standard
deviation so 12 is how many standard
deviations above the mean well it's
going to be almost 2 let's take the
calculator out so we forget 12 divided
by 6 point 3 it's 1 point 9 standard
deviations its z-score it's z-scores 1.9
which means it's 1 point 9 standard
deviations above the mean so the mean is
81 we go one whole standard deviation
and then point 9 standard deviations and
that's where score of 93 would lie right
there it's z-score is 1 point 9 that all
that means is 1 point 9 standard
deviations above let's do the last one
I'll do it in magenta D Part D score of
100 a score of 100 we don't even need
the problem anymore
a score of 100 well same thing we figure
out how far is 100 above the mean or the
mean was 81 and we divide that by the
length or the size or the magnitude of
our standard deviation so 100 minus 81
is equal to 19 over six point three so
it's going to be a little over three
standard deviations and well in the next
problem we'll see what does that imply
in terms of the probability of that
actually occurring but if we just want
to figure out the z-score 19 divided by
six point three is equal to three point
zero one so it's very close 3.0 to
really if I were to round so it's very
close to
23.0 - its z-scores 3.0 - or a grade of
100 is 3.0 - standard deviations above
the mean so remember this was the mean
right here right here at 81 we go one
standard deviation above the mean two
standard deviations above the mean the
third standard iation above the mean is
right there so we're sitting right there
on our chart a little bit above that 3.0
two standard deviations above the mean
that's where a score of a hundred would
be and you can see the probability the
height of this that's what the chart
tells it's actually a very low
probability and actually not just a very
low property of getting something higher
than that because we learned before and
a probability density function the
probability if you if you if this is a
continuous not a discrete but
probability of getting exactly that is
zero if this wasn't discrete but since
this is a scores on a test we know that
it's it's actually a discrete
probability function but the probability
is is low of getting higher than that
because you can see where we sit in the
bell curve well anyway hopefully this at
least clarified how does how to solve
for Z scores which is pretty
straightforward mathematically and in
the next video will interpret z-scores
and probabilities a little bit more